mình nên mình lên nhỉ
ừ ừ
à à
nói gì à
thì mình nên có bảng là bảo comment bình
luận mình sẽ bình luận à bình luận về
cái á à à
anh bình luận về cái cổ
có công việc đấy các thông số như thế
nào
à Cậu nó giống như kiểu dạng là đánh giá
và gần như là để gần gần như là dạng
hình ảnh
Ừ thì tôi ở đây này thì tôi ở đây là
hoàn toàn thấy đắng ở
nghe tiếng qua tôi đang định nói gì
anh bình luận bình luận để làm gì
ừ ừ
anh bình luận để mở hỏi đáp về gầy công
việc này giả sử Thế giờ xử thế bình luận
về hỏi đáp này cũng như là đưa đánh giá
các thứ thứ về công việc này góp ý như
thế nào vân cũng một cách thay vì kiểu
của mỗi mỗi một nút để tố cáo mấy ông ạ
Có một người nút được tố cáo
thì mình sẽ thêm cả một bình luận là xử
thế Tự nhiên cái đây mình làm sao cũng
được
gần như là kiểu ra bởi vì kéo có thể làm
cái cái thông tin ở đây chưa đủ nghe
Mình phải cung cấp thêm này ạ Nếu không
hiểu đâu
Ừ thì ví dụ là sử của bà đây mở lên file
này nó kiểu chiếu thông tin có thử thử
mình cần hỏi đáp thì giúp mình hỏi đáp ở
đâu Tự nhiên mình có thể liên hệ trực
tiếp kiểu dạng là ở đây Tôi đang không
đang không hiển thị ra người đăng bài
Hoặc có thể hiển thị với người đăng bài
nữa cũng được
Ừ cũng được à
Ừ nhưng mà giọt sữa với admin đang bày
như tôi chẳng hạn tôi là người đăng bài
thì được ra hỏi tôi không thấy nghĩa gì
cả thì một là trong file mà có sẵn trong
file rất nhiều file có sẵn cái phần là
phần kiểu thông tin liên hệ rồi rất
nhiều thôi nhưng mà không vẫn không phải
tất cả nên thành ra là mấy ông có thể bị
luận nữa nhưng mà đưa như bình luận thì
nó phải đồng nghĩa về cả việc duyệt bình
luận nếu hiểu cho bởi việc Tránh trường
hợp mà bình luận văng tục chửi bậy hai
cái gì đó Tam Linh giác ạ đúng không ạ
Được đẩy lên Nên là nên cách tốt hơn thì
mình sẽ không không đúng cái á Có thể có
thể có một cách đó là nhúng hẳn bình
luận của thằng Facebook vào trên trang
của mình nhưng mà Ừ nhưng mà cái đấy
mình rất khó kiểm duyệt nên cách kiểm
tra tốt nhất thì vẫn là mình sẽ duyệt
cái bình luận đấy
Anh đợi tin à
như ở nó có cái á
thế nhưng nó có cái gì
em nhớ có có hiển thị phố file bình luận
các từ từ có
Anh trông khá đẹp mà không
thì cái bình luận này thì đương nhiên là
sẽ bằng tài khoản nào đó rồi Và thậm chí
là nếu ở bình luận bị sẽ có và diệt bình
luận nữa
em à không có tố cáo bình luận được cũng
có là sự thế này
Cái dưới
à Tôi nghĩ là trả lời bình luận à bình
luận hai cấp
em xem giá xem nhé Bởi tôi đang định nhà
làm mình sẽ có một bảng bạn comment đúng
không Mình sẽ
Ừ anh có như sau mình sẽ có là bình luận
của bình luận của bài đăng này bình luận
của công ty
A và
Em không biết được có bình luận tiêu cực
không nghỉ à
không
có bình luận thì đây nhờ sẽ giúp sẽ mất
thêm thời gian để duyệt
ô hay thôi nhỉ
cái đấy làm sao được thế không hẳn Nằm
cái tính năng rồi nó không phải cái tính
năng kiểu mình nó tính năng chính ở
trang web phải không phải tính năng
chính trang web mình là gần trưa lên để
xem xem bài đăng các thứ thứ nóng lạnh
à à
Ừ có gì mà không hiểu Nghĩa làm chi là
bây giờ có nên hiển thị bình luận ở dưới
này không cho nó thêm nhiều thông tin
đúng ạ
chủ đề bài đăng bài đăng Đây là một bài
đăng gì nhỉ
bé đang tuyển dụng mà
phép heo này chúng tối tôi về quen nhìn
tối Nhìn chóng trong đau mắt quá
status tốt mặc định lên này hình như
mình chưa Wen mặc định lên đấy Mình đang
Hình như mặc định là tất cả đều lên đấy
đợi xem Đợi tí nhé
Ok đúng không ạ
anh ngồi bài đăng của mình đang mặc định
nhà nên
không có were thế nào sao tốt này
ở đâu Thế đi xe Wave nhau sau Tết là
mình sẽ là website tốt
5 là
thế âm inapro này
thế này
I Insert vào là ạ sau Tết là mùa
a
Smart start là một là admin admin page
size Nếu mà sửa mình kiểm tra nếu mà
mình là super admin thì mình sẽ mặc định
nó là hai thì có hồn hơn
đây đợi tí tôi sửa lại luôn mà tôi thích
này không mình lại quên ờ boss
boss
mua đồ đi ở
đài krantz Tết ở đây này sẽ tốt một Tĩnh
giá 1 đóng ngoặc
nhà mình có newsar ở đây cô dâu ở đây
mình sẽ kiểm tra là à
đó là
A là
I eat admin Superman theo dõi hàng nhanh
mình có bao nhiêu cấp độ nghỉ giờ mình
có
giờ pro5
I am in à Mình chỉ có Min thôi nhỉ
a cho tôi sẽ tạo một cái super mini Vừa
về sao với tôi đang định là mà tại sao
có khái niệm âm impending của vừa như
tôi hôm trước tôi có bà là giả sử Giả sử
là
giả sử là kiểu bây giờ cái cái trang web
này có quá nhiều thông tin tôi cũng
không phải là tôi không thể tôi vừa cốt
Tôi vừa Bạn thông tin được là sự tôi sẽ
nhờ một bạn cộng tác viên 12 bạn cộng
tác viên vào hỗ trợ tôi có việc à đăng
đăng bài các thứ thứ ngoan thì
Ừ vậy đi
status 5A
đề thi thì lúc đấy Lúc đấy thì gần như
là các bạn để đăng bài Tôi sẽ chỉ duyệt
tôi sẽ Chỉ lướt qua và vượt qua những
lời bài các bạn đăng về Tránh trường hợp
mà chính các bạn cộng tác viên cũng thể
đăng sai hoặc đang gì đó kiểu lạm dụng
quyền đấy Mình không biết được nên gần
như Superman sẽ người duyệt lại sắp cuối
chẳng hạn thế Thì tôi sẽ tạo thêm một
cái zô nữa rồi Superman đương nhiên à
giờ mình đang mặc định không có một cô
dâu rồi
vì nó không Superman
có thích mình hay sửa lại đoạn này
anh không biết ở chỗ nào nó ảnh hưởng
đoạn này chưa tôi đứng như admin vẫn vào
truy cập ở bên An ninh bình thường nha
Nhưng mà lúc mà có những về sau mình sẽ
làm tính năng liên quan đến Superman sau
bây giờ hiện tại toàn bộ tính năng biến
amin thì amin vẫn vào công tác viên vẫn
bảo xem được bình thường
về sau những cái nút kiểu Xóa ngay nút
mình chưa có nút xóa mà ngủ ngon
ở nhà có xóa chơi nha à
khu công nghiệp Bình thường và kết hợp
này ở Việt Nam mà
số lượng số bình luận được xuất hiện
được không thoải mái mà cốt Minh thoải
mái mà
cái áo Mister
anh sex code bro dài nổi lên nội xuống
đấy à
cái á
Xin chào đăng ký Nếu mà
đã tồn tại rồi phải trong cam còn không
sang cho đăng ký đúng ạ Tôi nhớ xóa sư
đăng ký cơ mà
à à
nhỉ Xem nhé mày đăng kí mình điên lại
thông tin đúng không
a fool nêm
anh ta
Ê kíp đấy làm gì nhỉ
anh ạ
Em sắp đê pro
Nguyễn Thủy
Vì mình chưa biết được vậy là muốn à
khi người ta muốn làm HR Hay là muốn ha
muốn vặn muốn đăng ký là her2 muốn đăng
ký làm ứng cử viên nên thành ra mình
phải mình phải làm hộ đăng ký ok ok nhớ
rồi
à à
Hà Nội Tội Lỗi
ừ ừ
em tự nhà mình đi ngủ xóa cô điện
à à
sẽ điều hướng
ghét về rô đấy
à à
mọi người sẽ truyền trở về Black này
tính nhất ở tí nha
gái đỏ nổi đâu có chịu đi ok
thì nó sẽ tự động Điền ngày nay
chị sẽ điện nó password
trước chưa chưa có rô Ok Ok ở đây là
sister này
Em định lý Đợi tí từ khi tôi sẽ quyền
hẳn lại cho hàng ngày Ai cần thì tôi sẽ
là à nhầm
ở đây là admin à
admin sẽ không Ly là một này
hay và R3 chẳng hạn anh ở đây best
Western này tôi sẽ chỉ cần
hai cái này
ở đây để đoạn này tôi sẽ
chị
sẽ có những rô có thể hiểu đăng ký ở đây
thì sẽ có ấp public tăng Trần là ghét
pro for Twitter này à
A và bản chất nó sẽ đi tơn về cái mặt mà
mình sẽ chỉ trả về cái mảng thì sẽ chỉ
cho đăng ký mỗi Hero thôi là sử Bây giờ
trước mắt là như thế là xử thế
ở
Excel à
anh em Lincoln và
HD
Lite
Android I thì mình sẽ cho thằng xa tích
được
và đây tôi sẽ lấy
an
toàn bộ tất cả các login a cho tôi sẽ
truyền là à
à à à Tôi đang cài thêm kể kỹ thấp
copilot nên mình không thể nó sẽ có ý
rất là ngon ngon hơn để thằng tóc nay
thôi trước à
Ừ cái này sẽ thì ra
ở Zalo này viết hoa
à à
ừ ừ
anh hỏi nhạc
thì mình sẽ còn em phối cả đây này à
ở
nhà như này mà mình sẽ ở đây mình sẽ
truyền truyền Alo trong ngày rồi
À mà đây sẽ
chị sẽ là tại Zone
Ừ cái cái thằng này Cái thằng này mấy
ông để ý kĩ là cái này đang là viết
tiếng Anh ngọn tất cả mấy cái này Thực
ra đang viết bằng tiếng Anh
sửa cả lại lại nếu không nhớ là chúng ta
bây giờ chúng ta sẽ viết như thế nào
chúng ta sẽ viết cái này bằng là
thì nó sẽ viết cái này bằng cái lang này
Phi Nhung giống tôi sẽ mở lại cái nào
nhé
à à
chị sẽ có trang xuất sự Translation dai
này chị sẽ
mình sẽ có đặt tên là pro đúng không
Anh ăn rồi đi
Em ăn Tết hometech Grow pro
cài
đặt tên thằng Lang khác như này nhé
anh fanpage này
a
cho Hero đây nữa
em ở đâu nhầm là ampli cần chứ cần
Vì
sao đây sẽ ra thằng này sẽ là ampli cân
à
Ừ đúng nhỉ ứng viên ứng viên đúng không
ứng viên trúng nhà người người tìm việc
à
thành viên hội đúng
ờ ờ tiếp theo nữa là hl
Ừ anh sẽ là
ờ ờ nhà Tuyển dụng
anh à
em hết rồi đi hết rồi
em lấy sẽ là nhà tuyển dụng
Ừ ok này
ở bên này mình sẽ là này
thì
mình sẽ có fanpage chấm
à à
đây sẽ là do đó
tự chọn bị ông xem nhé
mở cửa cho mẹ không xem à
a trai nó ta lại
ở đó
chủ tịch là thích cái thằng
3 cách mặc định trách là thiệp
Ừ ừ
mực bị trách thằng cuối cũng được cùng
trọng gì nhỉ
anh không sẽ thấy là tôi đang để nó toàn
bộ mình thì tôi đang để nó trang này
tiếng Anh thì như này đúng không ạ tôi
giờ xử tôi đội Nắng Mang web sang tiếng
Việt
ở đó
ạ bây giờ khi tải lại trang này nó ứng
viên nhà từ rộn Xỉn chưa chị được
mình đã làm là
ở ngã biến đổi cái chỗ cái theo
khi mình đã biến đổi cái này theo Phêrô
mà mình chọn sau đó mình sẽ in nó ra
theo cái ngôn ngữ của mình muốn hỏi
ở Hưng Yên mấy thằng khác phải thay đổi
Tôi lười quá gì sẽ sườn cái này sau
không ở lưng không có cái vụ mà cái cái
này cái này tích đúng điều cho vui chứ
nghĩa gì cả Có thể bỏ đi được thì
cho xem
à à
Có gì em nhỉ
ạ bây giờ sử đăng ký nhé Đăng ký này à
Ừ tí cho vui
nhờ đăng kí này
scrolling visa tỉ lệ ra tại sao đoạn này
nó bị sai nhỉ
a nampro
à mà
ở
nếu không hiểu thỉnh thoảng nó cứ bị lỗi
vụ là cái này là số Cái này là chuỗi
thằng Anh nó bị lỗi
Ừ cái này à
Vì mình thấy Ép kiểu cho nó đi vậy sẽ
Kiểu cái này ép nón anh à
hiệu in
thì bắt buộc nó là số
không bị lỗi nữa
ngoại
đi á tạo xả đi ạ Giờ tôi
lúc đầu chưa có vô gì cả
Anh định lô fo là gì nhỉ là một
định là một tất cả amin là
anh hơi say
thì mình nên để mặc định Bphone là
luôn đau luôn
cho xem
mới có bác nhà thì mình lên chưa lên lưu
truyền hay các thứ vào ở những chiếc pro
gì cả chưa lưu gì cả
Ừ
nếu mà
à à
sự tồn tại rồi rách cả thối này ok
Ừ
đợi tí đợi tôi một tí thôi Đang ngồi sửa
lại hết mày các bạn này nó hơi bị đơ bị
thoáng nó ao
nó cao rồi đúng không ạ nộp cho mình đã
download our có thứ thứ rồi ok Rồi này
đăng nhập lại này
a black về này
anh trọn đời này chưa có một tài khoản
là được tạo ra này chưa có vẫn là tao à
giờ tôi tạo ra đâu nhỉ À
anh ạ
la la cour phát nữa đi em ạ
à à
thì tại sao vật có tài khoản tạo ra đây
nhỉ
Ừ mình nhảy vào đây mà
em có user xếp rồi nghỉ thôi có chạy lên
cô dâu xếp được nghỉ
thì tại sao mình mặc định mình tạo ra
người dùng cái nhỉ
chun
đây luôn à
lại như vậy ạ
à à
là nó là nó có lưu lại
đây được rồi không nói in từ tao được
rồi sao
anh lại nhỉ Tao ở đây định nó phải chạy
nhỉ
Ừ vợ tôi bình tĩnh nha Đợi chồng tí nhé
hours
chỉ có vậy à không không remember thì
thấy nhà nó không lấy được thằng ảo gọi
ngu ra luôn
anh nói thế
ừ ừ
đi
Vì tôi luôn có một trang nó tan đi
à à
ừ ừ
nó chân đuôi lóc à
Anh remix
u-ear
em có ra vụ này
Ừ nhưng mà tại sao
họ điều hướng
xe điều hướng về cái này
thì nó lại không
anh nói vào get nhỉ
Em sang bên này sang bên Booster này nó
lại biến hàng
thì rõ ràng mà
ừ ừ
em alo để Twister của tôi đúng không
a
b ow đấy nha à
hai iPhone rồi
anh lừa lại lừa rồi lại giống hồi trước
rồi lại lừa rồi em
Anh nhớ là cái A
nghỉ ở đây nhá Không có vụ Hồi trước là
chưa step nên không lấy được anh đâu
đã lỡ làm vừa rồi mình chỉ thay đổi mỗi
cái đoạn là mình không remember nó nữa Ở
đây hai thằng log in này là một cố định
của lên bờ
à à
nó lên bờ vừa rồi là để nó lưu lại vào
trong
để lưu lại vào trong đây đấy
lưu cô dâu tôi vào tao bay Tôi không
thích điều đấy vì lô nó đang luôn Nó
đang là amin tự nhiên mình đăng nhập vào
với tư cách amin không được
à Còn nếu không thì không thì lại cho
trò kiểu Ok cho Đăng nhập thôi
định là 1
à mà amin
anh như thế thì tôi sẽ phải sửa lại đoạn
này tí
anh đi sửa lại đoạn music Dạo này nha
em mặc định nhà và Zone
em đi cần hết cho nhanh
à à
cả
ngày đúng không này và nghe Chu này
A và cái gì nhỉ và
anh đi sửa lại DB nữa
rồi để tôi cho cái này
anh sửa
bọn loạn rồi gì anh nhé
em em này enter có lum An tôi có luôn
do in user table à
thế
ba lô này
thì mình sẽ ở đây đang là số in cho này
defo nó là
I was Slow J5 này đấy
trên này thay đổi này
anh không không có dốc gì đấy Cả
Ừ tôi sẽ không có giúp gì đây
nó cùng đi đây cả À
Mà nếu có bạn nếu có quốc rô này cập
nhật Cái này là xong
à Tôi đang nghĩ là có khi ở cho rôn ở
đây
chắc chỉ cần đến nay rồi Tráng A
à à
mà chưa chưa Cho làm gì cả
Ừ để tí xem có được động và pisco không
Ừ từ gà người ta thì à
Ừ tùy từng lúc ông mới lên để cái defoe
trong tay giống như tôi vừa làm thì nó
sẽ hơi bị khó chịu là nếu là sự mày ông
muốn thay đổi về sau muốn thay đổi đến
phone đâu phải sửa lại sợ lại đã to be
như này thì cách hợp lý hơn là ông sẽ
hẳn ghi hạn ở trong cốt tượng như này
ông ông sẽ kêu ông sẽ bắt sự kiện giống
như là sự kiện à khi mà tạo mới như là
ai ông sẽ mặc định cho nó 1 cái đây khô
sau đó thì ông kiểu gì ông sẽ cập nhật
mà Bởi vì mấy ông thấy ở bên này có gì
mình sẽ cập nhật lại mà nó ngọn mặc định
mình sẽ cập nhật lại ở đây
ô hay vì thay vì chỗ ông lưu lại trong
database thì cứ mỗi lần ông ông sửa thì
ông sẽ phải sửa lại tao bây không phải
sửa cốt chửi tao bay nó sẽ phức tạp hơn
sửa Cốt nó Ngọc
đi về phía sau mình sửa cốt ở lại được
con không mặc định default Trong lạnh
được
ok ok à
để lại đăng xuất à
mà mong inch
à à
mắc định thêm Roman 2 Ok bây giờ sự và
mình truyền các thứ thứ luôn bây giờ
đang áp lực cân
về giá 123
khi đăng nhập này mặc định mình Bây giờ
mình đã đổi rô nó thành 3 OK OK cái đồ
đấy thế thành công Đấy Ok
a tiếp theo thì bây giờ tôi sẽ làm là gì
Tôi sẽ tạo cái hàm để mà kiểm tra là ít
Tôi muốn tạo một cái hàm nhanh kiểu ý
suplement Chồng Như Ý Cát từ thứ để kiểm
tra khá nhanh Chỉ đơn giản chỉ trả với
buôn lần thôi này
nó sẽ trả về là
em hỏi ông méo nhìn nó gợi ý hay ngồi
xin là ai nó đọc luôn cốt ở trên này nó
gợi ý ra này
à à
tôi muốn làm kiểu ngang như thế này để
cho vì vợ các bạn thì để mình lười thôi
cái thằng là lười thôi
lót thì ông cày ở trên vé code cũng được
không em một cái cho em ạ Giờ đây ở đây
mình sẽ kiểm tra đây này
thì mình sẽ kiểm tra soát tốt ở đây mình
sẽ là là
hình ảnh status nha sẽ bằng
Âm Nhạc
Ê kíp
à vì status khi mà đăng thì mặc định sẽ
ghét
ghét bye
cho phép bài gì
mình sẽ có copy đúng rồi đó
yêu
anh alo
Ừ thôi đừng như thế nữa
anh Hải xong rồi Bây giờ tôi sẽ chỉ cần
à
này nghe xong
khi bật nhạc
a a cái này phải đội nón stack
sức mạnh của Fast đây ạ
cách tôi viết nhé mà tôi đang kiểu đều
Nitơ Nitơ như anh ấy cũng thấy thay vì
ít béo cái từ thứ trong nó cũng sẽ
chuyên nghiệp hơn mà đúng không
đó mình sẽ ghét ba lô gần ngay để lấy
được cụ thể là xa tất trong trường hợp
là admin anh superbeam khi mà tạo thêm
mới một bài đăng rồi sẽ như nào ạ
á nhon
em còn đây mà định xa tất sẽ là ăn Mina
pro này
em theo
Có ai đâu mà tao còn chưa chia sẻ link
cho béo nhưng mà cái này không muốn ra
bằng tab la đâu nhé hồi trước tôi từng
tôi phải tắt cái Tab like cho rồi Tôi
đang dùng bản premium bởi vì à Nó ngốn
ram quá một tôi kết hợp với cả cốt with
me này mấy ông cùng truy cập vào cùng
lúc với mày Tôi đơ mày không hiểu ngoạn
rồi đấy tôi phải tắt luôn cái tóc nay từ
bây giờ tôi có dùng tắt máy đâu Nhưng
cái này không muốn ram đâu
khi ngủ vậy tôi không
tắt như tôi đã bảo là thư ca mình không
nên không nên viết quá nhiều truy vấn ở
trong controller controller mình nên rất
là ngắn thì các bạn này tôi nghĩ là tôi
sẽ viết tắt
ở đây sẽ có một cái public phong trần là
school là là gì nhỉ Scope à
I get up pro 12
Ừ thôi đừng gọi ý nữa
vì nó gợi ý Giờ hết rồi chẳng phải làm
gì mà chán vãi
à à I get up Crew Chính xác là tôi
thường này đặt tên không phải ghét mà sẽ
là Peter sẽ là
Anh hiểu hiểu rõ của Wake Up Girls
có một cách kiểu như thế của itou vật
hoặc là It's approved cũng được hả Ý ta
sẽ không đúng à
Thế Âm mưu vật cũng được thôi nhưng mà
chỉ cần như này thôi rất ngắn và và tiếp
theo tiếp theo với ông thầy đó à nếu bây
giờ xử Giả sử nhé tôi gọi tôi gọi Scott
này ở đây Như kiểu đồ vật như thế này
mới hiểu là là mình đang gọi đến cái
thằng này thì mới Ông thấy là nó đã cảnh
báo như này mà không tìm cái mới hết đấy
cũng như là màu là những ngày không ạ
Thôi chỉ trong mấy ông thêm cái nữa là
là IDE hepl không biết Tôi từng chỉ với
ông chưa đây mình sẽ cài thêm cái này
cài cái Pocket này để hỗ trợ và nó là
cài theo Dead với Cào nó sẽ chỉ chạy ở
trên trên một kiểu cài trên máy mình chứ
không không yêu cầu để chạy trên môi
trường để mà chạy trang web này
có cây cây xăng web này không cần ví dụ
Giả sử dụng kiểu đi Đức bios 3 cái hepl
tôi từng cài rồi này Ok Ok thế thì bây
giờ cách để viết
thì mình sẽ viết à lại cái chú thích cho
cái cái mô đồ này để nó nhận được mình
sẽ tôi tạo phím tắt rồi nó sẽ chuyển ra
là
có
đó sẽ đi thêm những cái hàm gợi ý các
thủ thử như này để để cho nó sẽ gợi ý
khi mà cái thằng IDE của ông sẽ gợi ý
chuẩn hơn cũng như là nó sẽ được hiển
thị ra có được đến đúng hàm số người mẫu
khai báo truyền và cái gì mà vận lại nó
sẽ như này Ok chưa
từ giờ sẽ chuyển ngắn gọi đến Khu vực II
vì nó không gợi ý Kiểu nó sẽ gợi ý cả
ngày thật ra không Hàn xịn lắm người già
nó màu màu chuẩn là được rồi
anh nói gì thì mua chuẩn
cơ hội được ký hiệu là mình đã từng khai
báo hàng đấy
Ừ để Cực kì ngon Không hẳn đâu ạ
thì cái thằng này nó đang bị báo lỗi rồi
kìa
post này nữa không ạ Mình sẽ có first áo
phê rồi đấy
à à
nữa bởi vì rõ ràng mà bây giờ không có
một cái bài đăng nào nữa đang được cấp
cứu người ông nhớ không ạ kìa bài đăng
tôi nỡ để nó là sẽ tốt là một đức à bên
đây thì mình sẽ update toàn bộ update ê
ờ ờ posts
anh sex status bằng
anh sex status
bằng hai là amin upload đúng nhỉ
a cho xe
ở ngoài bằng 2
gì hết Bây giờ như này vậy tại sao ra
được tất cả bài đấy không ạ Ok chứ sau
đó chị chưa
a tiếp theo nhỉ tiếp theo mình nãy giờ
mình đang đi hơi xa cái hôm nay ra làm
liên quan đến Nghệ tiếp tục ngồi làm
tiếp cái hiển thị ra cái đẹp và cái này
đúng ạ
Ừ cái này tôi Nghĩa lên thêm cái logo
nữa cho nó thì nó sẽ đẹp hơn hay vì chỉ
có mỗi kiểu như này bởi vì người dùng
được ra trải nghiệm người dùng Đôi khi
người ta lười đọc nhìn cái logo lại sẽ
ấn tượng hơn nhưng mà tôi cũng lưu 75
này nhà em thông cảm
mình sẽ có đây có 5 bờ - cần rồi
ờ ờ đúng rồi đúng rồi quên quên quên
quên quê tí mình còn làm phải làm cả vụ
lại có những cái bài mà tôi từng nó là
tôi giờ sự tôi muốn ghim nó lên đầu
trang Tôi muốn nó luôn được ghim ở trên
đầu cha có thể mình sẽ thích một cái ở
đây là kiểu đã được ghi mà chẳng hạn ở
có mấy cái thích
ghim ở đây này giống kiểu thằng Facebook
nó ghi cái kẹo thế Tôi muốn làm thế để
mà chỗ
Ừ thì mình sẽ làm như nào Tí nữa sẽ chỉ
Ông mấy ông cái đoạn đấy cậu Apple sẽ là
như thế nào đơn giản thôi
ừ ừ
sản xuất massage kem parttime
I can't Park here rồi nè
ờ ờ
vịt quay mình rồi con gì nhỉ À start
date vậy em viết đúng ạ Tát chết rồi em
biết ở đây thì mình sẽ ơi nghỉ thôi
chiếu cái thiếu trân trọng nhỉ
khi mình bị thiếu nhiều cái quá ông
chủ quan đó chủ quan quá thiếu nhiều cái
thật đợi tí
thì thiếu cái gì mình sẽ mình bị thiếu
cái đấy à Nếu giả sử Nếu mà giả sử là
bài đăng này
à à
sự người dùng cho cái hạn để Duyệt đi
thì là Nghĩa à Đang lại là mình sẽ có
thể nó sẽ có
222 cách xử lý ở đây tôi thường mới thấy
một là hiển thị ra đây là lâu và đã đóng
đúng hoặc nghĩa là cậu mấy ông có thể
vào xem Nhưng bản chất là là sẽ không có
nút chỗ dạng offline nữa chẳng hạn nó
đăng ký vào nữa là sư thế Ngoạ ta hiển
thị đã đóng và nó sẽ được ưu tiên thấp
hơn cũng như là mình sẽ có fit ở đây nữa
đúng rồi mình còn thiếu những cái fit ở
đây quên mất Peter là có thể parttime
rồi các thứ tư nữa chúng mình còn thiếu
một cái đánh đỡ à
a
standard hả Đấy ho Cách thứ 2 đó là đó
là mấy ông sẽ mấy ông sẽ kiểu dạng nhà
nghỉ
anh không hiển thị luôn mấy cái bài đăng
mà đã quá hạn ở đây chẳng ạ cho tôi
Nghĩa có cái fit Ở đây tốt cùng lắm là
mình mặc định mình sẽ nhìn thấy hết ra
rồi mình kèm thêm một cái là tích cả đây
là là
còn hạn hay hết hạn thôi đã đóng lại ở
Nói chung kiểu còn hạn hết hạn là đã
đóng hai con mới mặc định mình vẫn hiển
thị hết giả đây nhá á
làm thuần hết không có tí gj dư dụng gì
không có IP ai ở đây cả làm sai hết
ờ ờ ờ
cần hiện bây giờ như tôi đã bảo thì bây
giờ ra xử thật sự tôi muốn tin một cái
bài tôi muốn cho một cái bài là bài
Nội Đà Nẵng đi đặc biệt đông lạnh Hà Nội
Đà Nẵng này nó sẽ cho cái bài này pin là
một tất cả nó sẽ được tin nữa ngọn thấy
là status một mình à Không cho nó lại cả
cái này
Ê status bọn này thành hai hết rồi đấy ạ
thi thì tôi sẽ ưu tiên cái bài lên trên
cùng đấy ạ Tôi sẽ ưu tiên bài lên trên
cùng cho trước tất cả bài luôn thì tôi
sẽ order bye thêm một phát nữa Ở đây là
Order bye
dc-phoenix này nó ghét xong bài Hà Nội
Đà Nẵng của tôi luôn trên cùng trước tất
cả những cái bài khác nó hiểu cho em giá
sỉ trong ạ
à Còn nếu mà Mấy ông muốn chơi trò này
kiểu là là pin trên cùng ở mọng Trang
đúng ạ thì gần như ông sẽ phải lấy hai
câu truy vấn một câu lấy tất cả những
bài được ghim sau đó câu còn lại thì lấy
những cái bài những cái bài con lại
không được in thôi Sau đó thì ông sẽ
luôn chèn thêm cái mảnh những bài được
in trước cái mạnh những cái bài Bình
hưởng nhưng mà Nếu thế thì nó sẽ bị
nhược điểm trong cuộc sống kiểu bởi vì a
giờ sử bài được ghim của ông là bốn hạn
thôi những bài bình thường của ông nó bị
lẻ ra thì nó bị thừa ra là dưới Giả sử
thế thôi nghĩa cái này nó ổn ghim này có
là ghim trang một thôi mình chẳng hay
thì kệ đi ông ạ
xe tải
Ừ ok chưa đấy à còn gì nhỉ
Bây giờ mình sẽ thu hiển thị ra cái cậu
đã được ghi vào đây đúng không thưa gà
có nơi nó sẽ kiểu hiển thị ra còn ơi gì
không
a cho tôi cứ để hiển thị Nga thì trông ở
sẽ thế nào nha
Lại ngồi làm tao diện thôi
tôi đang không biết được tôi cũng đang
cân nhắc xem nó không biết làm cái biểu
tượng đêm này Hiển Chị đây á
thế này đây chỗ gì cơ
à Mình dùng cái kem rôn rốt này rồi cùng
mình không Mình không dùng ở luôn ạ ạ
thử Xóa đi mà
Ừ ừ nó vẫn thế
em ăn kết này là gì
xong rồi tôi nói chung à Xong cái này
xong cái giao diện bên này là con như
tôi sẽ làm bên A
Ừ tôi sẽ gọi à đi ploy cái này lên trang
web chứ có chứ
để đảm bảo để chui cái này nghỉ trên
cùng nhỉ
nghỉ
cáp hết đồ à
thôi đừng gọi ý nữa thôi
Vì sao
em hết
ở
nơi tôi làm thế nào để đẩy mất Thắng
The Flash Drive
khi sex
a a clock ở trên
bộ 10k thường thôi
em nói sao mà
[âm nhạc]
ở tại tra này à
ở trọ này không hiểu ổn
con gà mày đăng kiểu nhấp nhô cái này
thì nó đẹp ở trong bài blog nhưng mà
muốn cậu nó cố định cái thử thôi
Ừ cố định kiểu nghe nó làm cho
Âm Nhạc Cho hàm số kiểu mình không không
có bất hàng ở trên này
có ai nhất phải partition có nhớ phải
nhờ có season nó là là
Ừ đúng rồi đừng rồi knowledges rồi chơi
trò này vậy
chị sẽ làm cái gì ở rất là ngu xuẩn mình
sẽ có một cái
Ừ thôi đừng có ý nữa
Âm Nhạc
ở cả ba đi
anh khóc chẳng giống với cả à
à à a-class này
FA FA
I I love mem ơi mà đi chứ mà đi này mà
đi
mình sẽ có một carft nào
à à
ở nhà à
khi hết pin rồi đợi tí nữa xin pin à
ừ ừ
anh mơ đi chợ thế rồi thì áo matera Kids
mình đã cài mới đi đâu thế này mình chỉ
của ava thôi
Vì
sao người cái Motul thôi
em tin anh có
spin sping
anh internet
ở spiner
ông Martin
anh càng nhiều
khi sex
khi cài từ cái này Tom này rồi kết hợp
việc rồi à
là mất tiền thì bạn mất tiền
anh khuôn mặc định cái này không Tôi nhớ
tôi cài à xanh Cái
ngôn Mano Mano Lisa hả chứ gì
à à
thế này
các bạn
à à
An nó
giao rồi sẽ quen thôi Ờ
gì rồi nhỉ
Cứ thỉnh thoảng mình phải ngồi tra về
giao diện ạ Mệt không bị ta à
à à
Ừ anh mình Hiển thị luôn ngay bên cạnh
dòng chữ ít pin nhanh nhỉ ở ngôi sao
diện mới vỡ chưa
này
mẹ chăm sóc
em không biết à
Ừ cái lấy nó kiểu gì nhỉ
em nghe như nào nhỉ
nghe nhạc thôi nha à
bây giờ nó to ấy nhỉ
à à
a report hình sáng Liên quan không
ừ ừ
à à
em gà Tôi thích cái kiểu à Chéo cơ nhiên
nhưng mà chéo rồi thì thôi hết cái tạm
thôi Ờ
xe Vision passilat lò dai mà không biết
hôm
nay là 10
top cũng là 10A
Lê Ngọc Alo quá đi
nhà đẹp với ai không biết nhưng đẹp với
tôi
lại ít
ex5 nhân ái
à à
cho Asus
thế là xong
à
nhầm nhầm
à à
anh có xin được
vì thế quá được rồi
mẹ không đồng ý kiến nữa nghe đẹp không
à à
Thôi rồi không tốn quá nhiều thời gian
nó những cái hư đấy Ờ tiếp theo là bây
giờ giả sử là sử Mỹ xếp đét một cái này
là kiểu 131 nhập xếp date một cái á một
cái bài đăng là sửa mình hiện cho cái
bài đăng ngay bài thằng thứ hai hết hạn
em ạ sử là hết hạn vào
ở đâu chả sự là hết hạn vào ngày
quay trở lại không không nên cho hai cái
này đại khá hết
ở trong không nằm trong cái khoảng thời
gian hiện tại là được rồi
Nếu gửi thôi không nằm ở khoảng thời
gian hiện tại để sẽ ra từ lâu chưa ạ sử
thế nút Open hay đặt tên là nó Open hơi
bị hôn tạm thời cậu chưa duyên là sự thế
thì mình sẽ hiển thị ra một cái nữa tôi
nghĩa sẽ đánh dấu ở kiểu đánh dấu ở đâu
rồi trong hợp lý nhà lau ở dưới này nhá
bắt chước kiểu
một thằng ở trên cùng để ở dưới cùng nhé
Ok mình sẽ
anh thương em mình sẽ ở bên phốt mình
nên xử lý nên xử lý ở bên bên này sẽ
kiểm tra à là ghét
it slow
à à
It is not Open đ
Em đừng có ý cốt nữa mày không hiểu tao
nó định làm gì đâu
nữ ca sĩ Vũ Linh à
hôm nay sao mình bắt đầu So sánh là kiểu
nằm trong khoảng thời gian này không
không ạ Ở
ở ngân hàng lấy thời gian nằm trong cái
phạm video không
cả ngày đi ghi này
khi sex
Anh sinh năm như này thế xong đúng không
ạ
số đề ngày hôm nay đúng không ạ
đợi tí nhé về ngày hôm nay
anh cho thằng này nó vẫn bị stress time
nữa thời bị nguội
vào cái này là
cát ở đây sẽ vô tích cực
ở đây sẽ là
đây là nhé
ở Tab
hết lá
Ừ để mình làm việc với cái bếp nó
thế này mình sẽ
Khi so sánh kiểu nhà có nghĩa Thằng được
buồn đấy thôi nghĩa là thảm được luôn
đấy rồi nhé I
à à
cài đặt tên cả là khu rừng Tết hay nó
ngoại đi chợ so sánh với Đô la gi I
anh lớn hơn andiez
à Dạ đô la hét
lớn hơn nhỏ hơn bằng start
thế này
à Có sao mình sẽ gì trơn chú
nhé xong à
Xin chào bạn
câu cá trôi cách kiểu Nếu mà để để mình
dễ tim
à tiện hơn
nó vừa gọi í a tôi trở nhà cho nhanh
rồi sao Ừ thế được
là kiểm tra đây này
đóng cái Deep của cái đít này cong
nghiep của clip này
a bit content
Ừ cái này phải nằm trong nick ten đúng
không ạ
từ
các container
thì mình sẽ lại ít
I
work it
anh nói open
cho
em ít
mình sẽ đây sẽ có một cái à biểu tượng
clâu đi Tưởng nó đóng
a close
anh FA close thử nhé in
À lát mày
fa-close I
thứ ngày
Ê mày không có
Ê thằng Bình Dương này chắc chắn có mấy
nhỉ
anh ạ
anh không thấy nhiều nhiều
có nhiều bê này à
nhiều Hà Nội đúng nhỉ Nhiều Hà Nội đấy
Có ai đi là 21
22 phải đóng phí nhỉ
anh tí Đợi tí nha
a slot Open Until You
Ừ đợi tí từ thước Dolls and ask em ạ
có ai Tôi sẽ
có giá trị thì tôi sẽ ở đây sẽ có cụ thể
là que idd
đó là hai một hai a
nghe thấy không so sánh được mình so
sánh ở đây mình sẽ so sánh như kiểu là
cho đến ở đây là format
[âm nhạc]
anh nha
u-ear
ở đây như thế Tôi sẽ ghi hàng cụ thể đây
đi a and AD
a map kia Monday tự thế với Stars
em
có mát như này cho mình chưa được so
sánh như thế này cho xong
à à
đúng nhỉ
Ừ đợi tí nhá một tí
xem được
à à
Ừ đúng rồi hôm nay lớn hơn còn so sánh
kiểu nhà thì ra
Ê mày lớn hơn thì đúng
à à
hai iPhone hôm nay không
Ê mày không nhỏ hơn mẹ sao ở đây nó
không ra nhỉ Đợi tí
Lê Ngọc open
à Có sao
a What is not Open nó gọi đến ham này mà
có gọi hàm này
xe Hyundai HD
cho xem
à à
thằng hai à Rồi
à
à À rồi rồi tôi bị ngược Tôi bị ngược
lỗi tội lỗi tôi đâu thôi
thế này nó phải như thế này
vi hình nó là nó Open rồi nội tôi bà xã
không đạt
Vì sao
à à à à
Gợi ý sĩ phết I
ở chung kết này
I not open
ở
gần nhà đó mình sẽ tạo một cái
bộ phim set tạo một cái ở đây
Translator bay rồi
thì mình sẽ tạo thành một cái ở đây nữa
áo kiểu tại thời điểm này không mời à
nghe đi
tôi cái cái công an sản xuất văn bằng
bác ạ
cô gái sẽ là chỗ
ờ ờ
cái này như thế này hết thời hạ tạm hết
hết thời hạn thì họ sẽ a note of edible
nha
ông xã
ở các kiểu cầu A
cho sự sẵn sàng cổ nói
cho tao vay bố Nova e a simple
tôi sẽ đổi Anh Việt I not Open ina
It's variable ngay
Ừ nó
đi
khi bật lại gì It's not available for
khi bị nhầm đấy
Ừ nó vô à
à à
I love Apple bình thường thì kệ rồi
thực là tôi khuyên là mấy ông không bắt
chước như tôi là nên viết hoa hết kiểu
như ai nên viết thường sau đó đi anh em
mình sẽ xử lý và viết hoài không chứ vài
rồi ngày chứ về sau mình lại phải chị ạ
Đã hết toàn bộ từ này nên nên là viết
thường hết sau đó thì mình phải nên mình
sẽ kiểu Tùy theo tùy tình huống mình sẽ
biết hoa hay không
Ê bà
anh không khả dụng những dịch thu ở dưới
anh nha vô tra là gì
đã có sẵn
tiếng Việt cái này bây giờ bây giờ gì
nhỉ à
có hiệu lực
anh có thể dùng
Anh đang mở cái này đang đóng rồi đúng
không sẽ ra hả
10 cái này nó te ve bồ hiện đang mở được
khi đó nhà
anh
không còn vợ được gặp ờ
à à
đít vào đây chả thế
spa
spa nó là person
nói mình sẽ chứ thằng kia thôi ngược lại
nó là
ờ ờ
dai cũng là mười tính
em gái
không biết Mười biết nói đi ừ
anh không khả dụng á
công việc cũng không hiển thị giờ chứ
không khả dụng em buồn cười
xe tải
thật luôn
sự thật này luôn
Bet now theo cái này thì lấy nào rồi
được rồi những con nào
à mà nằm trong khoa Mai
ừ ừ
duy-tân Trum Ariston
liveshow Còn bây giờ mình sẽ tenchu II
anh sang nha
ừ ừ
Ừ
nếu mà cái này nằm trong khoảng này cái
này Note thì sẽ là ngược lại đúng không
bí ngô lithophone ngoài
khi con không Mình đang mặc định lấy
Tuấn Du
31 định thằng dưới nữa sẽ là Return a
nhà tôi nghĩ đoạn này có thể làm kẹo đi
Tân phone trước một loạt cho nó nhanh
cho cho nó dễ hiểu hơn
vì vậy sẽ à em đấy à Nó đi Tân Phone này
nó bị xóa đi được đoạn này
à Xong rồi à
Em nói như này
à à
em không có Start Dash 2 and thì mặc
định là có nhiều bỏ qua không kiểm tra
gì nữa
mà lấy kiểm tra là nếu mà kiểu nằm trong
trong phạm vi này những cái đúng Nếu
ngược lại chứ lại ạ
Ok chưa
cho sinh nhật chứ đúng không
rồi nghỉ đợi tí khí thải các-bon rồi nó
không cần phải Cacbon Passion nữa đâu vì
tôi đã khai báo nó là cass nó biết như
này nó biến thành các bon rồi mà lại nhá
á
Anh nói thiệt không đàn bà gợi ý
em bị cùi
em
mặc định nó carbon rồi bởi tội khai báo
nó các sở ở đây nó là biết rồi thì nó đã
nó đã tạt hộ mình thành các bon rồi em
mình sẽ chích kiểm tra như này thôi tôi
đưa tôi biết cái hang beequeen ngon phết
Ừ vì vừa nãy mình mới chỉ tra là check
betwin ở bằng TP Chúng Mình Chưa kiểm
tra chiếc bằng len hoặc chế tạo out Chắc
nó ra hàng này luôn thì tiện ông ạ
em lấy chồng nó sẽ như này không ạ
à Xong rồi mình bụi bữa mày được ra hả
cũng khá nhiều đấy tính giờ này vẫn còn
nhiều đấy
ở ngọn
Xem tổng hợp quốc hôm nay nhé
chị xem hôm nay làm được thuê với gì
không Mình sẽ khi tơ thêm được cái gì
khi tôi không nhỉ
tơi nhanh để hiển thị ra đây là tổ chức
bóc lá kéo là hả là campell Ham chẳng
cô gái say thì làm cài kenpas Tâm ở đây
nó kiểu chiếc bóp
ờ ờ tiếp theo là
Đó là kiểu dạng mà Kiều mình sẽ chắc là
là có làm lạnh Office được không có làm
tại remote được không cô gái trần thế để
xem thỏa mãn được 1 trong 2
Ừ đúng rồi
nhớ về Sapa đây
Ừ cái đi ra đi làm tiếp
ừ ừ
fire đây này
à À rồi
em hết định tùy
a-class tree lại trưởng đặt tên
had Won thật luôn
sô-cô-la One
phải đi à
cái thời khó chữ thập
ở đây là
location à
Em sắp bị trùng IDM nhỉ Chắc không
profession
Ồ vậy à
a fine thế xong khỏi Chung
bộ phim heo
Ừ nó lặp lại này có bị sao nhỉ
Anh không chắc không được
à à
là Peter
Ê pete ơn lên để trước gặp Day Hay là
không có Trọng ăn đâu
ghi chép file cũng được
à à
Ừ
đợi thì
- post
cái gì đấy
Ừ anh em ba đi à
anh alo
body này
span you live
à à
thì mình sẽ có 1 Exciter ở đây đối ngoại
ở
một cái tổ
ờ ờ any body
à à
A1
cho nên nó sẽ là Ken remote
à à
em ở xa
thì mình sẽ in ở đây là
anh fanpage này
anh Ken remote à
xem nhé
cho nó rồi tôi sẽ tích ở đây đông ạ Đã
có thể mình 120
Âm Nhạc
ông ngoại tôi sẽ tạo tích vào kiểu như
thế
tí ý ăn mì đây sẽ thêm một cái nữa không
ạ cài đặt trên remote ở đây như này
a scan remote I
Ừ cái bên này sẽ ra đó có thể
viết hết chữ hoa lại tôi thấy nó hơi xấu
để vết thương được hay vậy
thì tại sao kem remote này tích vào này
cho bị làm xước nó sẽ truyền cái remote
bằng một lên trên này sau đó mình sẽ chỉ
cần hả
I work rồi đấy có được không ạ
thì mình sẽ quay theo cái đấy chuyên á
thẳng ngay luôn được
anh alo Where can remote thằng ngay
được
đúng ý nhỷ
ý kiến part21 còn vmode thì
Ừ ừ đúng nôn cái remote lại bồ rồi đúng
để xem nha
Hà Tĩnh có thể làm từ xa này
có một cái là thế đi ỉa ghen à
ô ô fish
ở Vietcombank
nhỉ
nghe tiếng Anh nó lên là gì được nhỉ
ừ ừ
Ừ cái kem remote rồi ông ạ Có thể làm
việc từ xa đúng ạ Bây giờ mình làm nào
để mình hiểu được là là
em có văn phòng ở đúng
em không nghe chưa thoát được nghĩa lắm
đi làm việc tại có thể làm việc tại văn
phòng
Anh tên nó nghe dịch nó bị giải dòng ấy
nhỉ
Anh nhưng mà cái cái đấy tiếng Anh không
Word in Office
dùng nghe không phải là tên biến what is
your feed
đấy
Cái này hoàn toàn hỗ trợ cả hai nghĩa là
dụ Giả sử giống như thế Lần trước nó là
gì à
222 bớt đấy
em nhớ nhớ về cái vụ hãy bớt không
I would a remote
số bài 5 nick này
Hôm trước à Ông ấy có hai bớt đi
I
have crisp Everest đấy là đã có thể quốc
phòng hôm hoặc là ở bất kỳ đâu đấy
high priest mình đi sang ta à
à à
Em hãy Cường như thế
Bây giờ mình làm nào để mới hiểu được à
có thể làm tại văn phòng
nó dịch ra bởi lạ nhỉ
chỉ muốn lên văn phòng để làm thôi chứ
nó khi tơi như thế nào nó sẽ người hiển
thị cái gì khi tôi
ngay nó kiểu remote à
ừ ừ tôi nghĩ hiểu thì cậu sẽ lấy gót
chân nó kéo thì đúng kiểu vì mốt only
Office only và Hybrid như thế sau nhà
Ừ tôi đã định kiểu hình theo chiếc bóp ở
đây người ta thì chọn
các loại kệ
Vậy tí nha trợ thính nhá sẽ là
ghét à
Ừ từ này
là gì nhỉ à
thuở trưởng linh hoạt đi sẽ làm việc
linh hoạt là để xa
anh đi
thế Chúng ta sẽ cắm cái đó ở đây nhá sự
cũng Selection đây đúng không Mình sẽ có
một cái Android để mà hiển thị ra
cơ cấu hình địa La đây ta
Anh bình thường anh tiền đây sẽ có dữ
liệu rồi có ai ở đây à Sao
ghét Zalo rồi cũng trợ à à
à à đâu không lấy bao lô mà lại acai đây
rồi đấy cho mình sẽ
ta này ascii
Zalo không ạ
à à
Lê Minh Tâm bây giờ mình cần sửa lại cái
key này khi này như này thì người dùng
không hiểu sẽ sửa lại cái key này bằng
cách là
à à
Ừ Thì
vn-index đi sửa lại cái này như hôm
trước có bạn với ý tôi cho cách đấy của
bạn ấy khá chuẩn nó kiểu đổi cái này
Thành à
chỉ tôi với cái thái thổ ấy mà tôi không
để ý
sẽ đổi cái ngày thành cái
em không có con
nghe vậy Tự nhiên được thôi Chỉ có Trinh
tu lau thôi cứ để làm gì
đáy led của thằng này
Ừ Tôi muốn in line của thằng này mà
cho iPad 2 Plus
em có khi này sao rồi
à à
ừ ừ
lucky cháu giới thiệu
các bạn này tôi làm thì ông sẽ hiểu được
tại sao tự nhiên tôi làm lại gửi Tôi
muốn làm kiểu nhà nha muốn làm kiểu sẽ
lấy góc chân kiểu nhà này
sẽ có ích này
có tiền mình sẽ
sẽ có cái tờ
Ê pete ơ
post remote I
Ừ cái bồ bằng
boss remote
table i5 này gọi Lấy cái hàng này
À hôm nay xã thích rồi Ok Google
à à
khi
truyền hài và bên này đúng trước
như này sau đó thì bên này sẽ bị sẽ
nó làm à sẽ có khi
vào lô này
yên phối này à
Có tin hót xuân ở đây này
à à
cả ngày đúng
là fanpage này à
em
ăn pate chấm xôi nối với cái thằng kia
thế này cơ đó lấy tác dụng của tôi tự
nhiên tôi lấy được cái mạng này nó sẽ
kiểu nhà nha à
Ừ tôi có cái mảnh remote police office
Tony và Harvard đối ngoại cho tôi sẽ
truyền nó vào fanpage và như này
và bên này tôi sẽ có là
anh xóa mấy cái đi này
ở đây sẽ là remote con đi nè
à à
bộ remote only Hạ
em chỉ làm từ xa đúng không Ok chưa
khi họ Gala Office for lease đúng không
Ừ ừ đoạn Vừa rồi con nhận à Tôi làm đến
đến bây giờ mới ông ấy hiểu tôi làm gì
đúng không Chỉ làm tại văn phòng à
chị sẽ à
lý giải hợp lý thôi
em nghe Làm việc linh hoạt chẳng hạn ạ
ờ đúng à
chứ không phải linh hoạt gọi gì à làm
tại một nơi à gọi là
Anh không quan trọng nơi làm việc à dịch
cái từ này như thế này nhỉ Sao
[âm nhạc]
biết là gì em ạ em ạ
à à
đó là việc kết hợp văn phòng làm việc
linh hoạt làm tại và phòng làm từ xa nữa
Làm việc linh hoạt đi à
như này à
ở nhà đổi sang tiếng Anh nhá Idol sang
tiếng Việt nhé
Anh sang tiếng Việt chơi
tiếng Việt chưa
em đăng ký đi Tiếng Việt có máy nghỉ đấy
đúng không ạ
tiếng Việt
Ừ ừ
đúng rồi
Cái lanh nhìn trông rất là mệt đúng
không Nhưng mà nếu mà ông không làm sớm
còn bé hơn đúng không Sao ngủ Sửa vỡ mồm
các bạn này
Ừ Ok đúng giờ
em mãi mãi không lấy lại cho không lấy
được sinh ra nào
làm sao trong sân của mình có mấy nhỉ
cái
Ừ thì có đúc kết là Vi mà Tại sao không
đi thì cái này tôi ra
thì tại sao ạ ừ ừ
2plus
mất Con đi
Đúng rồi nhỉ
chẳng cái cùng đi đấy
anh không nghĩ ra nhỉ à
cho vay nghĩ tính
nghe tiếng Việt chứ
ừ Địt nữa tiếng Việt của tao đâu
thủ tục kết nạp đi rồi mà tìm việc có
được không có ấy nhỉ
Ừ được rồi
a section II
à
à Không thích sân là một chuyện gọi mình
là xuân là một chuyện Đợi thì đợi tí
Ô kìa con fish
Ừ đợi tí đợi tí
luôn mặc định là
Ở đây có nuclide mà
anh em
a b d e f
cho phép lô kép thuộc sẽ nha à
Ừ tại vì đây
a a phòng không Trên anh xóa đi
số còn lại web Tại sao nó không chạy vào
Google ID của mình nữa nhỉ
xin lỗi à
ừ ừ
em ở nhà
à À rồi Tôi hiểu tại sao rồi
khi bật lên đây là được
Anh ăn chưa Alo cái rồi ngày to lắm hả
bài đăng
có bao nhiêu đâu liên quan gì nhỉ
Ừ cái bài đăng à
I take a Rồi rồi không phải mức giá ok
Ờ đang đóng ok à
ở đây là sự Minh
em làm việc linh hoạt này chỉ chọn rồi
xa bởi Tôi muốn lúc đầu là à Nếu thế
phải cho một cái lúc đầu nó tất cả nữa
nó mới ổn
không chọn không chọn cái này thế này
tôi mới định để chết box này không chọn
đi ô tô à Không đi
ồ là tất cả mọi
tất cả
khi nghe xong rồi à
Cho nó tất cả nhờn chưa
từ lúc đầu cậu mặc định thích vào phải
tất cả cho mình sẽ ấn sơ như này chị sẽ
truyền cái à
Ừ cái kiểu dạng ngày lên đúng không ạ
gì nhỉ
bộ remote Apple không ạ thì fable II
ông truyền lại
kiểm tra là là đây là
kiếm cho thẳng luôn mình sẽ có quy mốt
thời bồ đây sẽ bằng
bị quét này
cho phép remote table ô
nó với ý cả ông đúng không chịu vãi nhỉ
à Xong rồi Nếu mà kiểm tra à Nếu mà
không trống thì mình mới Peter theo nó
được sẽ que
anh được
du lịch
Ừ thôi đừng nói gì nữa làm ơn thì sẽ que
remote thấy bồ đây đấy
à à
ở lại
À mà em không biết cái này đúng không
cái này nó là kiểu theo cột về luôn ý
viết tắt của Lara cũng hay cũng hay
nhưng mà thôi Kiểu như này được à à
à à
ở tại trai
Khi bữa nào tất cả bọn Tôi sẽ chỉ cho
em làm việc linh hoạt này
anh không có
chỉ có 1 tháng 01 tháng 01 tháng ngủ nha
Anh đúng là có một thằng ngã ba thôi sợ
là tháng 2 là gì nhỉ
à hay là
tại văn phòng
ví da này rất nhiều
ở Hà Nội mình phải nhôm mình phải thêm
cái đoạn nữa mà mình sẽ phải tích lại
cái cũ nữa
ca nhạc tất cả các cũng ah
em ý mày
đó sự tất cả thằng cũ
Âm Nhạc
chị xem tại văn phòng ok
vì
sao mình sẽ là cặp
ví dụ chọn là xem từ xa
thế là ok chưa
hôm nay nó sẽ như thế hôm nay là mình sẽ
có làm việc thêm rồi được à Mình làm
quen được thêm
làm quen dần thêm việc là
làm việc với kiểu ngôn ngữ đào nữ nóng
lạnh
truyền truyền ra nhưng lại các thứ thứ
Rồi tôi tạo những cái hàm tóc kiểu ngay
từ
khi vọng với ông thẩm thấu được à
học cách để đẩy dần lên Quá nhiều thứ
mình đây ạ
ở đầu tiên thì luôn là mình luôn lên đẩy
trước cái file ta Bây này luôn để trước
phải tao bây
tiếp theo
cái này cũng thấy đây này
em thích cái nick gà Mình thấy ghi rõ là
cụ thể là cái gì tôi lừa quá rồi
ờ ờ
ở những cái thứ không quan trọng tình
nghĩa nó những thứ mà gấu uống nó cũng
chẳng kiểu ảnh hưởng lôgích lắm thì mình
đầy cho thế
Ừ cái này mình sẽ free format này Nhưng
mà cái này sẽ đi kèm cái khác nữa chắc
không được
Vì sao những cái gì bây giờ mình đẩy
luôn đầy phấn chấn lên này viết phương
trình này vì thế ghi rõ là cụ thể thêm
hàng nào các thứ thứ cũng được Nói tiếp
theo là update những cái J5 này
chợ
tết năm này
anh nói sau đó thì mình bắt đồ đi đến
update hiểu cả mua đồ và cả controllers
rồi mới đến view đúng không ạ sẽ như thế
format lại nó theo cái kiểu như này nhẹ
bớt là một cái nữa này
số tiền mình là mau trước đi gọi out này
ở đây đây ngon áo này mình sẽ liên quan
đến vụ là
cái này làm gì nhờ cái này nó đúng kiểu
đi không mát rồi phải cái trang này vừa
nãy mình format chẳng làm gì cả
À thế à format này
có mát nghĩa là ngồi kiểu thay đổi cho
cấu trúc cốt
chỗ cho nó kiểu căn chỉnh các thứ chứ nó
không nó cũng không có thay đổi lâu xích
anh xuống dòng enter thì chỉ đói Xóa bớt
đi là kiểu
Anh ở cửa này phải Reboot lại
à à
Huy vus
Master II
Có 2 cách để tivi nó sẽ ngã update này
đi bớt ký stones and Còn gì nữa không
thường mình cập nhật mua đồ mình để lên
Con gái bây giờ mình bắt đầu ngồi chỉ
những cái này
em gái mình sẽ đẩy lên thì sẽ là Blade
Twitter
Tết ở
a Tiếp theo là cái bản chất à Mấy ông
tùy với ông có thể kiểu chiến giản đoạn
này xử lý lô gic nói ít khi ông có thể
chị ghi chú khi ông tạo Hàn file mới thì
không có thể ghi cụ thể hơn còn những
cái kẹo sửa này đôi khi là sửa mỗi giao
diện trông thể tôi thường ghi ngắn gọn
chỉ update này là như thế tôi cậu mình
đã hôm nay mình đẩy lên nhiều phết gọi
3 cách tách ra khỏi nhà để làm gì để về
sau cũng chỉ cần ấn như này vivos trà
sữa Ông thấy có một vấn đề gì đó không
sẽ đi vất Cụ thể một cái gì đó thôi
ok chưa thấy buồn Hôm nay sẽ à em rất
dài kết hợp việc là
dù tổng kết lại cho mấy ông rồi đấy hi
vọng mấy ông ạ
anh có thể hôm nay không hiểu mà hôm nay
hiểu nhưng không nhớ nhưng mà
Đấy do mình lưu lại video mà kiểu gì Xem
xem lại gần sẽ hiểu sẽ nhớ thôi Chả mấy
ông nhá
âm nhạc có gì thắc mắc thì vẫn tiếp tục
lại nhắn tin hoặc bình luận sau nha à